jason powell a member of the house of
representatives in tennessee he's put
forward a brand new build that will
allow the state to invest in
cryptocurrencies what am i talking about
this brand new bill would propose that
counties municipalities and the state
could invest in cryptocurrencies and
nfts this was one of two different
legislations that are related to crypto
and blockchain he asked that tennessee
lawmakers consider forming a study
committee aimed at making the state the
most forward-thinking and pro-business
state for cryptocurrency blockchain and
to foster a positive economic
environment for blockchain and the
crypto industry now of course what he's
relying on here is the 10th amendment
the 10th amendment for many of you who
don't know is very important the 10th
amendment specifically says the power is
not delegated to the united states by
the constitution nor prohibited by it to
the states or reserve to the states
respectively or to the people now the
reason why this is important is because
maybe we don't need to wait on the
federal government to actually start to
participate in the bitcoin
cryptocurrency industry maybe this is a
states right issue maybe what we need is
our state lawmakers to go ahead and push
forward to say maybe we should buy
bitcoin maybe we should invest in mining
maybe we should be putting this stuff on
our balance sheet if this is a states
right issue the federal government is
going to lag behind and the states can
lead from the front tennessee is not the
only state that's actually going and
doing this though there's plenty of
other crypto friendly states we've got
states like florida where florida
governor ron desantis proposed the state
government allow businesses to pay fees
with cryptocurrencies including bitcoin
we've got a bill that was signed in
kentucky by the governor andy beshear
who reduced the sales tax burden on
crypto miners operating within their
borders and then of course the senator
wendy rogers from arizona introduced a
bill proposing to make bitcoin legal
tender in the state ultimately it
doesn't matter what each individual
state is doing it doesn't matter what
the specific nuances of their bills are
what we are watching is a wave of
support for bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
across the united states and it's coming
from the state level not the federal
level the states aren't going to wait
around for the federal government to get
their [ __ ] in order the states are
ultimately going to push forward they're
going to innovate they realize what's at
stake here and ultimately what is going
to occur is the united states is going
to embrace bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
because there is no other technology on
the planet that embodies the ethos of
this country more than bitcoin and
crypto bitcoin and crypto are here to
stay the states won in on the action
it's great to see the lawmakers in
tennessee florida arizona kentucky and
many others all jumping on the bandwagon
game on let's go